se sont-ils suicider ou ont-ils été
éliminés ces dernières semaines ces six
hommes d'affaires russes ont été
retrouvés morts à chaque fois les
similitudes sont troublantes
la semaine dernière en espagne sergei
protosser n'y a été découvert pendu dans
sa villa de la costa brava une hache et
un couteau maculé de sang se trouve à
proximité les corps de sa femme et de sa
fille sont également identifiés
sergei protosser n'ya été l'ancien
directeur général du géant gazier russe
novatek actuellement visé par des
sanctions occidentales dans le contexte
de la guerre en ukraine selon
l'entreprise russe la thèse d'un triple
meurtre déguisé ne tient pas
malheureusement des spéculations ont
émergé dans les médias à ce sujet mais
nous sommes convaincus que ces
spéculations n'ont aucun rapport avec la
réalité
mais l'histoire de sergei proto sénia
interroge car elle ressemble à celle de
cinq autres hommes d'affaires russe
spécialisé dans le secteur de l'énergie
retrouvés morts eux aussi en russie ou
encore au royaume uni des oligarques
tiraillé entre sanctions occidentales
loyauté et trahisons au kremlin dd c'est
aux apparences de suicide dont la
succession jette le trouble